[Music]
okay enough of that this is not going to
be a cinematic vlog here I'm just
showing you what I've been up to lately
and right now I need to get from London
to Las Vegas and back again in 72 hours
this is guaranteed to be a jet lag
disaster but I have a plan my body is
going to Vegas but my sleep cycle is
going to stay in London on GMT gray
master time I'm changing continents but
not changing time zones I think this is
a great idea everyone I know thinks this
is ridiculous
but I'm going to give it a shot let's go
what the heck is that
planes wander around on the runway for a
long time so you always have to check
and see when is it gonna be real it's
real okay this is future gray here
editing this video and who obviously
survived the flight I'm not normally
worried about the actual plane this is
not where my travel anxieties come from
but look at the wing of this plane as it
takes off it really bends quite a lot
from the original position now I have
flown a bunch I don't remember ever
seeing this kind of thing before and I
found it extremely concerning normally
this is the exact moment where my travel
anxieties end and once the plane is in
the air I can just sit back and read or
work or whatever and just feel like I
have a bunch of time on my own but I
couldn't help but keep looking at this
wing and how much it bent is this normal
it doesn't seem normal anyway back to
past grey who's actually on the plane
it's the very vlog that I hope you're
watching right now is something I'm
thinking of trying to do on this trip is
like an additional thing but I gotta
tell you this wing outside the plane is
extremely concerning like it's not just
me right it's really been okay I've been
working on the vlog for a little while
but if this plan is going to work I need
to get to sleep because there's only six
and a half hours of flight time
remaining it's noon o'clock in Las Vegas
and eight o'clock in London which is a
little early but I've brought sleeping
pills of unconsciousness they're blue as
all such pills are legal
[Music]
oh god it's really early
all right gotta get out I'll make him
some sleep in the hotel
[Music]
traveling into the u.s. sucks this is
where I protect my phone this is where I
protect myself
[Music]
Vegas baby alright it took me way longer
to get through the airport than I was
expecting it's almost 4:00 in the
morning in London but it's almost 8:00
p.m. in Las Vegas and I wanted to sleep
a little bit when I got in it but I
don't have time because I have a dinner
to get to at 8:30
okay future great here I did make it to
the dinner on time but I didn't film it
so here's some stock footage of puppies
instead and now that we're taking this
little break I'm going to let past gray
explain exactly what the plan is in
detail let's take a look at London and
let's take a look at Las Vegas 1:00 a.m.
in London is 5:00 p.m. in Las Vegas
drawing out the rest of the hours gets
us at this relationship between the
times around 10 o'clock
I am definitely asleep which expanding
to eight hours later gets us to around
six in the morning when I'm usually
waking up this means in Las Vegas I'm
going to be asleep from about 2:00 in
the afternoon until 10:00 p.m. my eight
or nine o'clock at night is still
lunchtime for people in Las Vegas so I'm
definitely available then but if I'm
willing to take away two hours of sleep
I can actually make it for the time when
most people want to have dinner which is
eight o'clock at night normally that's
my nightmare having dinner at 8:00 but
this time it's working in my favor
crazy normal people like to stay up
until midnight which I could never
possibly do but now this is looking like
a real possibility there midnight is
just my 8:00 in the morning at which
I've already been awake for three hours
anyway on London time so there's a big
overlap during this section even better
when they go to bed it means I have the
rest of a full working day essentially
on my own no one's going to be around at
4:00 a.m. in Las Vegas I can just be
doing whatever I want it's my lunchtime
normal business hours start at 9:00 a.m.
which is my 5:00 in the afternoon so as
far as I'm concerned this actually works
perfectly I can see people in the
beginning of the work day I can meet
people for their lunch I can be around
for people's dinners and I actually get
to be the guy who can stay up late for
posting or socializing a first in my
life and I get a whole chunk of time to
myself I don't see how it could possibly
go wrong the only thing I need to do is
just make sure I don't fall asleep at
the wrong time
dinner over which was my breakfast I'm
pretty tired but it's 10:40 a.m. on
grain after time I can't fall asleep so
I'm going out for a walk to actually see
Vegas for a little bit I think this
really is the city where I think this
plan can work because if there's one
place that doesn't want you to know what
time it really is its Las Vegas the walk
helps now it's time to take advantage of
everybody being asleep but I need to
find bingo target acquired
time to return to home base and edit an
episode of
[Music]
it's a funny setup but it worked all
right I'm getting pretty tired when I
shouldn't be so I'm just standing in the
Sun for a while to remind my brain to
stay awake before heading off to meet
some people for breakfast and then lunch
but I didn't film that so here's a
sleepy Hedgehog instead all right it's
9:30 in London even though it's only
1:30 in Las Vegas and I am exhausted
it's been a long day I lost more sleep
than I expected because of the flight
and the time it took to get to the
airport but at least one day has been
successfully accomplished but now I am
going to bed
okay this is the first time that I'm
waking up actually according to the
schedule so far so good I have a 9:30
dinner that I need to go catch which is
actually going to be my breakfast you
know the drill
people stayed up until way late this
time
I'm never the guy who gets to close down
a party because I'm mister in my pajamas
at 8:00 p.m. but now the tables have
turned and I can be the last one who
stays awake I have the whole day ahead
of me but I'm skipping to the end
because I don't want to spend my whole
day filming things but I saw a big shoe
I saw some robots taking our job took a
car met some people for their lunch and
my dinner and now I need to go to bed
pretty quick because I need to wake up
earlier to catch a final dinner here
the first few minutes of waking up or
not great
normally but when you have to wake up
just a little bit earlier it makes a big
difference but I know just just get into
the shower and get going I was a little
bit late and a little bit lost trying to
find my way to dinner but boy was it
worth it my steak for dinner breakfast
is over and this is my last morning in
Las Vegas and there's something I want
to do what is a vlog without a montage
so I'm grabbing a car to the other end
of the strip and I'm going to film my
way back as the Sun rises walk with me
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been pretty great time in Vegas I
spent the rest of the day just packing
and getting ready to go which is totally
uninteresting and now I'm setting my
alarm and a timer because I have to get
up very early to catch the flight home
future gray here because past gray
didn't have a whole lot of time between
when he woke up when he had to get in
the car and when he had to get to the
airport
it wasn't close close but it was a lot
closer than I would normally cut these
kind of things the flight was at Las
Vegas 10 p.m. time which was London 6
a.m. time and this flight home turned
out to be the hardest part of
maintaining grey master time this was a
night flight back all of the lights were
turned off I was darkness the entire
time the plane was in the air for what
had been 7 a.m. for me but I had already
been up since about 3:00 a.m. getting
ready to go to the airport and boy did I
want to sleep to make matters worse
power in my seat didn't work for the
vast majority of the flight so I was
just counting down the time I
my laptop to work to give me something
productive to do instead of just sitting
there in the darkness trying not to fall
asleep but thankfully the nice flight
attendants kept bringing me many many
cups of coffee and eventually got the
power in the seat next to my own working
so that I could keep doing stuff the Sun
did come up which really helped them we
flew above the clouds for quite a while
and nine hours later descended through
them into the ever bright and beautiful
England then back through a much easier
security trains and eventually home to a
normal day where I could go to bed where
I was going to wake up the next morning
to see if this test was successful was I
able to go to Las Vegas and come back
without disrupting my regular sleep
cycle woke up to a foggy London this
morning I know people think the city
always looks like this but in my time
living here it rarely does so he's try
to appreciate a good fog when it comes
in a little tired which is to be
expected given that I've got at least 2
hours of sleep off each night for the
past 3 days but the very fact that I am
awake in London at this time in the
morning after coming back from America
it feels like a miracle normally when I
come back from America I sleep in really
late I feel really terrible I'm just
jet-lagged and I'm totally unproductive
for a week well right now the plan is to
head into a cafe and work on one of the
final drafts for the next video that's
going up that's a huge relief that this
trip didn't destroy a week's worth of
productivity and I don't know if I'll do
it but I feel like it opens up the
possibility of doing a shorter trips to
America in the future well see as for
this vlog that you may or may not be
watching I don't know if I'm going to
finish it I don't know if I do finish it
if I'll put it up on the channel and in
particular I don't know if I put it up
on the channel if people will like it
but for now it's been at least an
interesting fun side project to have
that's like a little bit of a secret
which you dear potential future viewer
may or may not be in on but right now
I'm going to enjoy the rest of this
beautiful morning